this is so fun it is one of the most
popular wedding movies around probably
one of the most popular comedies around
we're talking about bridesmaids and now
it's getting a musical update Valerie
Witherspoon the writer of this
incredible musical parody and we have
Annie Unger I'm sorry Nicole Unger
playing Annie younger well you know what
we'll just call you Annie
I like it ladies this is launching
um next weekend is when people really
need to go get tickets but the official
day is Wednesday kind of a soft opening
how excited are you to bring this to Las
Vegas oh my gosh so excited it's such a
good party and it's it's so perfect for
the city it is perfect we were talking a
commercial break with a number of you
know bachelorette parties that come here
it is that moment to really celebrate
Brides how I guess what can people
expect from this parody a really good
time a nice night out um some wild
things like you know they poop in the
streets there's you know we do
everything that's in the movie is in
this and a little some extra things as
well so it's just a fun funny night out
oh yeah for sure so you sprinkle in a
little bit extra but there is I was
gonna say you know there's so many
famous quotes from this movie and one of
the most popular of course is it's
blowing out of me like lava so there is
that moment yeah today we're just doing
a bit of it yeah that's in there as
we're watching video clips here as the
show that it shows how about how long uh
90 minutes 90 minutes of pure Chaos on
stage I'm sure yes
um
I I is there any parts that people are
going to say this is different from the
movie than their expectation oh yeah for
sure changes we have new characters we
have uh just things that are different
and then all the the most iconic scenes
are all still in there yeah iconic
moments are still there so the heart of
the movie is still there but we've
sprinkled some fun little extra things
just a little bit okay well and now I
have to ask and of course I have to
mention here you guys are both actually
and friends as well which plays at the
Orleans this is a very different show
than friends but um and Nicole and that
you're performing in both and Valerie
this is you wrote this so how is that
different from actually performing in it
a little bit of control difference yeah
I get controlled so it's nice let's say
like say that differently or I would
never say that to you
okay say that differently but yeah just
to get to like to shape it and kind of
create it what was the idea behind
writing it where did they where did it
come from we wanted a lady party we
wanted a late night show that could be
dirty and could be funny and like a nice
girls night out date night like a late
night show yeah a late night show 18 and
up yes
if you want to all right uh Friday next
Friday ticket's still available you
might be able to find some for Wednesday
but you're gonna have to look carefully
uh folks all the information is going to
be on our website ladies thank you so
much for being here today
congratulations bridesmaids at The
Orleans go get your tickets oh yeah
and with that we're going to send it
over to Sherry she's got a look at the
forecast